hi guys it's been a while this kind of
setup it has been a long while actually
since I've just sat down and played just
a little indie game for you guys this
game is called a flippin death and it
was kind of a mix mash of Psychonauts
and a little bit from bo ish it seems to
be very narrative driven and I love the
art style for it and I like anything a
little bit dark and this kind of reminds
you of the Disney film Coco as well so
anyway the developers reached out to me
asked me to play it and they've given me
some goodies to give away to you guys if
you want to win just some little goodies
about this game and I will put some
stuff of my own in there as well then
make sure you're subscribed and leave a
comment telling me what sorts of games
you want to see me play or if games
aren't really that much interest to you
anymore
I would like to know is that something
that I've been kind of dealing with
myself you know me I like to do a lot of
different content I'm not too sure
whether I should start playing games
more so I want to know what you think
because I've stared in my live streams
but I mean in this format I haven't been
doing it as much so do you miss it
do your not let me know and you could be
in with the chance of winning a giveaway
anyway
let's play this game and see what it's
about I'm very excited I haven't played
a little indie game in a while so let's
do this press escape to play
since okay
pressing escape to play death
it's the final punch line at the end of
everyone's life though not everyone gets
to laugh you ensure own end soon enough
the story isn't about you this story
about the hometown flatwood X you'll
find a variety of pleasant folk
including one young lady and hanging to
world earth and is just a regular person
with a regular job but be dreams
disturbing interest stories and it will
stop climbing the corporate ladder at
work eventually
[Music]
the friendship sheets or belt obsessive
quest for class that stories about you
okay it's great we're going fairly sure
I'm continuing on from that I like the
break in the fourth wall day because I
think that's stuff that everyone would
you like us to send your restless soul
perhaps it shall reside in the jar of
that last payment or for nominal fee
mayhaps into the wooden closet about to
be lowered
let me just check my husband's will mrs.
Dewan I do appreciate your passion for
performance I'm afraid this is one
egregious step too far
come on Halloween is in a few weeks
good but this is a funeral home
well you can't fire me I quit
you can't quit mrs. Dodd I just fired
you
my quitting is retroactive boss how's
that taste okay so this is the girl this
art style is so unique collects little
papers cute okay no that way hey bunny
come on boyfriend you trip penny can
easily find a new job and she's got a
boyfriend
peasant penny is in a bad mood and you
have to cheer herself up and food movies
and switches are gonna be you wait why
[Music]
so I need to go to that grandma well how
did [ __ ] my husband put in his will that
I really did want to be catapulted into
the Junior I love me jumper sorry I
won't be able to help you ma'am
that's okay dearie
[Music]
when I press up she just kind of
flickers I'm trying to press up to see
if it it's like an action button but she
just kind of and you can see I'm
partying
oh well hey can you drive
yes brandy so instant peace passed penny
who had a job that didn't let her have
fun next stop
anything but that
yes I can relate
as you know I can't I'm kind of pretty
good job once I like them yeah once part
of the uniform and I had to pencil it
into the dress code and don't worry
about the job you'll probably fall into
a new one within the week ideally it'll
be the one that lets me keep the spooky
Halloween theme yeah where I get a fancy
dress store
I'm RIT oh how do I get out and I talk
to this dude okay
check out
yeah I really wanted like Dracula theme
park and B is a very thick
whoa are you okay fine not hurt at all
actually that was really lucky good
mm-hmm
we better get back before the fog gets
even thicker we can take care of the car
later okay come on let's cut across the
graveyard really we almost died once
today what are you afraid of ghosts
penny if a real ghost appeared you would
probably be a little afraid now I just
say holy crap a ghost and then be
totally cool classic me the humor
reminds me of like Bob burgers and stuff
like that which I am very happy with Wow
he is having fun with that trash can
oh well mausoleum let's check it out I
don't know as you can see it's perfectly
[Music]
oh my god she said I think she died it
can you do will it just be fun
this was not the first time she been
fired for in her words just trying
driving things up but it would be her
last
yes she's dead deciding not to let a
funeral home bring her down any drove
off with her boyfriend Elliot didn't I'd
have a fun night out and were it not for
someone or something appearing on the
road in front of them oh yeah I wish I
agree
seeing something on the road then he did
the sensible thing and crashed her car
into a tree Sam Gipp looking for penny
this didn't kill her
unluckily for penny sneaking into the
creepy old mausoleum for make-out
seconds for me to crash through I
totally missed them when they got in
there for me give her the end thank you
for playing no it's no shut up eggs to
skip holy crap oh gosh she said it
[Music]
heute no see there must be a mistake
because I am an alive human hey a man
alive she ran lots of dirt around after
that there's anger and bargaining both
on and then depression or the slave
dragged okay good luck on your journey
I'm not in denial
hey wait where do we go not that way
whoa I can jump so much cooler now I
don't know what I just said whatever
maybe is about Michael Jones when you're
dead you can do somersaults I've always
wanted to do so so welcome to the party
sorry not dead also not in denial
there newbie don't forget to book the
spot early if you wanna place
it feels up with ghosts fast I'm not a
gum wait
there's a spot there's a cesspool of
Tears kiss it don't think I'm going to
spa hey sorry to interrupt
that's diocese but I think there's a
small chance I may have died um somehow
and wait what are you doing bargaining
demons aren't allowed on this level
Oh demon I'm not a demon I'm actually
the temp I ordered finally the tenth the
temp finally after one billion eight
hundred and twenty five million nine
hundred eleven thousand two hundred
thirty eight hours with the moon you've
never been it's the one place near Earth
where nobody has ever died no ghosts no
demanding restless spirits just a
peaceful wasteland of rest relaxation in
Barack collecting this over three
hundred thousand kilometers from the
nearest soul that's good
can't wait you'll need this site okay so
wait gonna be the Grim Reaper I'm sure
lady elder Doe can provide any training
you need she clearly believes she knows
what's best for everyone
are you you innocent
well goodbye
let's go without vacation nice it didn't
give you any training at the temp office
did they uh no because I'm not just
typical alright I'll give you the basics
see those ghost critters I need you to
catch them throw your side up there the
news it's switcheroo powers to tell
about yourself right to it
wait this thing teleports no way hey
that's awesome
I can definitely be the tab lady and
then how do I do cute wait it's gonna
get used to this man keeps falling ah
all right you're not as completely
useless as I'd feared ah thanks it's
time to possess a human possess like
actual crawl on the ceiling while
vomiting possession that's rarely
necessary see that chap once you have
enough ghost critters try possessing
hearing
what chap oh she's like pointing you
can't NGO sense how do I do this again F
F V oh this is insane
I'm actually inside this guy's head and
there's all these things I can hold what
does this do these two tariqas - man I'm
the best at naming ice cream flavors I
can name 50 of them no problem including
two secret flavours from the government
what are the secret government flavors
you know questioning that the random
moisture and to detach the ice cream
cone seems like you learn all sorts of
useful things while mine yeah turning
less useful you know what happens if I
push here
okay cool
all right that's enough Tim I'm pretty
sure I got murdered
I remember getting married in then BAM
court City oh you know thoughts Vale
killer is brought to justice and
freezing my typewriter summons someplace
cold and it smells like I won't say TV
dinners go find my killer temp I have a
feeling you should check my bridegroom's
mansion it's up in the forest you got to
cross the leg that way
oh so that's how come nobody can escape
death there's a magic map on his safe
right it all makes sense I can teleport
as well so why is the forest hey did you
notice that weird yeah I did up there
I'm pretty sure I saw it grab a monster
thanks for the tip need any hand with
that fire on your head or what do you
mean it grabs a monster Hey
aha I see old secret mistress has caught
your eye huh why the boat grandmother
ain't her myself funny
after me mistress are you insane I
absolutely did not what my most well
that's kind of the point of a mister is
holding a book that you effectively
names the SS I'm having an affair I need
a picture off that it did well my wife
murdered me a jealous rage nicked me
before I could finish painting my boat
oh they're blanks need now a fresh coat
of paint
I can finally rest me weary bones in
peace
okay so I'm basically avenging
everyone's death so they can be peaceful
Oh mate I've heard tape
oh boy her tail the old paint factory
over yonder they still have a we drop a
paint for you oh good okay alright
where am I going I'm going to like the
forest I where's the forest oh I'm an
idiot I just realized it's to get over
there I do need that boat so I mean yeah
okay I am interested in your mistress
not that I'm it's just the boat okay so
let's go figure out where I can get me
some pain just like it's trying to get
me I don't think that hand is actually
going to do anything
woo oh my gosh oh wait who is this oh
it's a man that I can bless you trying
but didn't take something with a little
more hood spa to get inside his head
have you seen any of those rare ghost
critters around
I know I've seen some up by the forest
was it kelan's quite remember Brad ones
oh this is the forest I think so is that
someone else that I can
can I possess this yeah I can do this
what an odd person there's nothing more
evil than poking things Hey
don't poke things anymore oh I need him
to I need him to oh yes please poke this
one the pain oh hello I don't what are
we doing where are you taking me
thank you
[Music]
oh my gosh
super touches smoke oops I'm sorry I
made him move and hurt the girl thanks
career counsellor big a dentist was such
a great idea it's not like I wrote I
hate bad breath and floats open mouth on
my application and underlined it five
times
right the queasy dentist resolved to be
calmer I will no longer engage the rage
quit unwanted inner voice I'm trying to
make me better
we might go spits this rocks okay I'm
gonna go right now
no outside about to lay the SmackDown
[Music]
pretty much the best you need to stop
eat an ice cream young man I know what I
need to do I need to make a hole in that
paint box right because I need to paint
[Music]
my god okay it's gone now
okay I don't need to just beat
man even my Jasleen goes out your way
well hello what am I trying to do it we
sure like each of these people have a
reason that I can possess them maybe I
don't know maybe maybe not
so I just need to kind of like make this
one come with me
[Music]
getting more little spirits I like the
effort that's gone into just kind of
building up each cat oh my god each
character is van oh no there's no way I
can do this without hurting myself but
yeah this mechanic I don't know if it's
just me huh come here
come this way get me get me come here
come to the hand yes aah
Oh fry this hitting my XD here just
moved it to the other side
nice ok now I need to open the paint can
I would get in somewhere so now we've
come like we've gotten to know the
people so we know that we need the
dentist man don't be
yes we need the who dentist man so where
is it okay we need to get do drill a
hole through our paint can so we can
paint the boat he's got a point
don't buy expensive food but then I
wouldn't waste my money
oh I forgot it's totally flip so the end
of it is on the right instead of the
left
oh I like her gave you a hint because
it's got the the doctor thing Oh
meanwhile we're off to get married we'll
be home for tea what I can what is that
number five what was wrong with the last
boy what'd she say oh that's all the
matter nothing my dear love nothing my
mother was just speaking out of turn she
was sneaking out of the birds
Oh No leave the poor Lydia learn front
of a horse awake painter hopefully
okay so we can go in here one day face
yes maybe space
George pouring ttan that makes sense
he's his marrying and killing for money
right
George is blessed to live in interesting
times
his only discovery may you live in
interesting times was a Chinese curse
much later on at which point a lot of
things in his life started to finally
makes sense then he discovered that the
expression wasn't actually a Chinese
Crested
[Music]
[Music]
nobody should marry nobody okay
[Music]
[Music]
where is his head gone oh my gosh he
said just came off his tray someone else
ah you sir see what's going on in this
guy's hey yo beam marrying rich old
women and killing them for their money
was a bloody excellent idea
hey George I don't think you should do
that
Oh voice inside my are you my conscience
yeah engines yes yes George
he sees your conscience speaking don't
listen to your punch no we are not
controlling her about the bait how much
mercy do you have to lay his head going
for
come on Oh
he's made an old sea dog happy today
oh it was my pleasure but let it all go
sleazy dog give you a word of advice I
would wager my last jib sheet it's not
aa spin that killed lady ordered oh yeah
I pretty much assure you that one out a
small glass upon them there Thanks
i ah secret mistress by a fierce and
more than mistress Oh
- alone starting to wonder whether his
mistress was actually the boat go
investigate the husband's house up in
the forest
hey oh maybe I have to be this dude
again
[Music]
such a cool lifestyle it's like so
unique I love it
[Music]
moonshines magical mystery okay yes yes
you're on the right track his mansion is
supposedly up in the forest come on I'm
very cold
try throwing your sin on the flying
monster oh yeah I did this before
Hey oh no bring backup please Oh what's
this is this a bear a dead bear I can't
believe it
I'd take care of this forest my whole
life then I get shot by somebody's mom
and they built a house right on top of
my favorite spot this is the opposite of
justice now I'll never rest until this
house isn't moved out of this forest so
what you're saying is this situation is
unbearable
ah how could I move the house residing
on his den what's this oh it's like a
special one
oh so this was the forest where they
that those special ones are that I need
to possess I get I'm guessing people of
authority because it was only the what's
good the policeman that I couldn't do
before this hello word chopper oh wait
[Music]
cool somebody skip leg day what still
looking good man it's nothing wrong with
caring about how you look
what's that it or not a lodge you think
I look hot to his eyes make him look
absolutely freaking terrifying hey what
do I need to chop Pet Sematary
[Music]
oh this is pretty creepy wake up the
sleepy man right ah I didn't even know
why I did that but I did it lady dang
living everyone can see my waist and
hanging out now I've got all I need to
possess that cops body against his will
which sounds horrible when I put it that
way so what's now why is it gonna win
hello game not sure what I just did but
I think I did something actually a
really good place for you to be zoning
wise
okay
why did I just do that I'm really not
sure
finally the houses oh I'm so happy I'm
almost unbearably happy what what did
you know I use a different permit really
happy
well watching horror movies lately check
the basement
[Applause]
here's my son John his judge and whoever
is kawaii face - I guess what I say okay
so I need to find wait Jay King George's
the other dude jerking this is George
I have him for his name he was like poor
so nothing are you George
yeah it's don't hate me yeah oh yeah
they haven't seen my why I say mother
it's murder
it's always been murder Oh Deary there's
such an imagination on you welcome home
sweetie now I can use the cops come and
like find it on me Oh girl [ __ ] - oh so
you can't run away
perfect okay so now I need you please to
take me to bed Zaheer going at the cup
and the cup can come and then with him
we can find out when I find that guy get
that guy caught red-handed ice tongue
now I'm not even a bit right okay
where's the okay now I can find I can
try and get him yes
oh let's listen to what his fine this
way you can do this you can get through
this day without messing up about - when
does the murderer yeah go you this is
thanks in your voice you hear much
louder than usual today
Hey
[Music]
we're going to avenge someone's death
and we're gonna feel great about it
let's go it's adorable
hey I'm a police officer
shouldn't shoot me you shouldn't shoot
anyone really but but we make the laws
so you need it extra bad to shoot us
he's stuck somewhere else but if I
promise not to take your guns will you
promise not to shoot me we have an
accord and of course for like in
accordance hey he never heard of that I
[Music]
have the right to remain silent anything
you say can and will be used against you
in a that's what America officer what
you know that new creep confident oh hey
yeah you're going away for a very very
long time
she had a big diamond sorry you got
murder eyes lady oh it's okay happens to
the best of us I'm afraid and thanks to
your help
my spirit dearest I was alive I was
always afraid to see a goth out in the
street but you showed me today that
scary black clothing exactly I met when
I was a kid I used the most bad thing
ever oh right
thanks again dearie you're very welcome
oh well things were looking out we're
from liberal enough ok so that just
crashed randomly but it was good timing
because we literally just finished the
first chapter I really hope you enjoyed
that game I really like how quirky it
was and love the art stuff for it's so
unique and different and I can
absolutely see how some people have
compared it to games such as Psychonauts
and things like that because of its
humor it was brilliant
the concept of it it's like really cool
I mean I was still struggling with the
grappling hook a little bit but I don't
know if that's just me because usually I
do play console more than PC but let me
know what you thought about this in the
comments below and like I said before if
you are subscribed and you comment you
will be in the chance of winning a few
little goodies from this game and I'll
chuck in some extra bits as well so I
will let you know that in a few weeks
time are we sending an email to the
person who has won so also make sure
your email is attached to your YouTube
channel so
I can get in touch with you anyway have
a lovely day or evening and I will see
you in the next video
bye